[Music]
doug is with us doug is in tampa florida
hi doug welcome to the ramsey show
thanks dave
um i was calling because a little
background story um i used to be an
addict in gambling
and uh i've gone ahead and been sober
for three years now good for you well
done how'd you do that
uh
well honestly lost everything
okay
it was uh kicked out of the house lost
car
uh kicked out of another house and so
that's kind of where i was leading to is
that how did you get did you get help
from somebody ga or what
no um actually my daughter's my fiance
now
uh
was uh just by my side and said that you
know in order for us to keep a family
together and for me to be
to be around my daughter was either to
clean it up or
not be a part of her life and i couldn't
really
see that in the future
so um wow kind of a little ultimatum and
and uh so sucked it up and went on with
it so you've been dry three years
yep
um so i you know i was able to get the
finances back under control
uh start paying bills on time because
working
was i was able to see the money coming
into the account i did you know i have
debt with the evictions and the repos
but no active debt no credit card no
student loans anything like that
so
the reason i'm calling is because i back
to
the situation to where i'm not spending
money at a casino but i'm
you know i don't know where my money's
going i see the paychecks coming in by
the end of the week i'm
back down to the point to where i'm
getting scared where bills aren't gonna
be paid on time
and i don't want to
relapse per se and get back into the
situation where i go make three four
hundred dollars real quick just to pay
the light bill yep
i like that i like it i like it you
recognize the
the tightness in your chest and your
throat right
yes yeah that's smart that's wise okay
now uh you are your fiancee did you
marry
uh we are getting married at the end of
the year okay well congratulations on
that okay so here here's the thing
i want you guys uh it sounds like you're
married or it sounds like you're living
together with a baby right
yes okay
so um you know as soon as you're married
you need to be sure you're doing this
but between now and then you can
practice working together
on the budget
okay so here's the thing the way you
stop living hand to mouth is three
things
obviously
if we lower expenses that helps
obviously if we increase our income that
helps but the most important thing is to
live on a plan
a written budget will make you feel like
you got a raise in your case
what it'll do is give you peace
right
because right now money is a stress
point
it's a it's a it's a an area of great
anxiety
and uh me and my fiance yeah well i mean
she's scared she's scared you're gonna
do stupid again you're scared you're
just gonna twist out and not know what
to do and so here's the thing it's a
pretty simple idea but you have to do it
with a gr with great discipline and you
will a get tremendous peace from this
and b you're going to feel like you've
got to raise
so here's how it works i want you i'm
going to i'm going to sign you up for
financial peace university to learn how
to handle money and in that you get
a uh for a year i'm gonna put you in the
ramsey plus for a year okay it's a
membership thing we're gonna put you in
there for a year in that you also get
our premium version of the world's best
budgeting app it's all free for you okay
it's called every dollar now the premise
of doing a budget is this the number of
dollars you have coming in this month
not a template
not the perfect month from heaven but
this month today is the first in
september what dollars are going to come
in you put those at the if you just draw
you know just to get a yellow pad and
put that number at the top of the page
and then i want you to give every and
that's you and your fiance i want you to
give every one of those dollars the two
of you working together to do this
an assignment
the first assignment that comes out of
that is food
the second one is lights and water
the third is you keep the transportation
rolling and the fourth is you pay the
rent
now if you've got all of that covered
and by the way you can
right then the rest of it is just kind
of monopoly
okay because once you know you have a
place to live and the light's not going
to be cut off and you got food
your stomach relaxes
that tightness in your chest starts to
go down and you go and i still got
thousands of dollars laying here on this
pad i've got to figure out what to do
with and you give every one of those an
assignment and then oh by the way you
live by that once it's done
you don't spend money on anything
anywhere anytime unless it's on that
freaking paper
got it you're in charge of the budget
until it's done and then it's in charge
of you
you get to decide it you get to decide
but then it tells you what to do
how would i go about the uh the
non-active debt
per se
uh don't worry about that after or
that's the last thing you deal with
first thing we deal with is get this
crap out of your life that's where it's
all swimming around in your head and
about to blow your it's about your
head's about to explode right
right we gotta get rid of that first but
then once you get past all of that then
way down the list is going and cleaning
up the past
okay and all you're gonna do there is i
you know with the exception of if
somebody's suing you or something i
would just list those debts smallest to
largest and i would look at the smallest
one and i would call that one and work a
deal with them
not a payment deal a lump sum deal
just pile up cash yep in writing so i
chose a repo uh uh a tentative eviction
and what else
that's two two tenant evictions in a
repo that's it okay
so uh have any of them giving you a
number
no i haven't gotten any judgments
nothing no no no no request for
collection no nothing
no i haven't and it's honestly been
three years i mean so i haven't i mean i
have so here's what's going to happen
let's say you call up landlord number
one and uh it was an apartment complex
corporate operation and they say we
added it all up and it's six thousand
dollars you say i can't do that but i do
have two thousand
okay they'll take it
okay i'm gonna have to argue with them a
little bit but they'll take it
you get that in writing
in writing do not do it unless it's in
writing
and do not allow anyone to have
electronic access to your checking
account you give them a money order a
prepaid debit card or you give them cash
and get a receipt
okay perfect i don't care what it is a
certified check whatever but don't get
them don't let them get in your checking
account
because they'll clean you out
so each one of them are going to name a
number that's going to go like the repo
you can sell that repo for about 12
cents on the dollar
okay
and uh
it's just for the deficit if what they
sold the car for subtracted from the
balance plus they've added all kinds of
repo fees and legal fees to it you just
got to cut that back down and hey man
you're going to turn this around i can
tell you you're a guy that's you've
changed your life and now i get to be a
tiny bit of the back side of the story
so you hang on kelly will pick up and uh
ken and i are going to give you ramsey
plus
for a year
which includes financial peace
university
and
every dollar the premium version a lot
of other things as well but coaches are
in there everything's in there
pretty cool